[Music]
I know Pam's going to tell her version
of it will you tell your version of it
no you know what it's been told that
respect her for telling her version
because the version they told was
somebody else's version Maybe
you like the attention that's insane I'm
actually doing my version
what's your version of the really messed
up version
well one thing is for sure at 59 years
old Tommy is on track to stay a bad boy
for life
just last month he posted a since
deleted full frontal photo with the
caption oops has your wife put your your
social media on lockdown
um kinda I don't know I'm on probation
he's not on prove you'll put Tommy on
probation yeah I mean you always I mean
we've been on probation
hard to believe Motley Crue has been
doing their thing for nearly 42 years
and there's no slowing down Nikki just
co-wrote the title track for the new
horror film The retaliators in theaters
today
Tommy has a cameo that is perfect for
Tommy seems like the perfect role come
on was it the perfect role for you well
yeah I'm DJing in some strip club
then of course there's Motley Cruz sold
out stadium tour which is filled with
multi-generations of fans
like in the meet and greets kids sold
over sign since my 10th birthday today
[Music]
foreign